escape room kicks off 2019 with the
first horror movie of the air there's a
lot to unpack from this movie's puzzling
plot and throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about the film and its ending
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about the movie then I highly
suggest that you turn off now but for
everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I ruin it so you don't
have to the film follows six complete
strangers made up of Zoey Mike Amanda
Ben Danny and Jason the characters
really could not be more different than
one another and their job roles range
from financial executive to military
personnel however they decide to come
together and participate in the escape
room due to the cash prize that comes
with clearing it and the fact that they
were gifted it by a loved one that was
close to them each room has been
specifically designed with one of the
characters in mind and they all have
elements within them that will mess with
the characters on a psychological level
these elements force the characters to
look within themselves and at their past
and some of the aspects within the room
to influence them in different ways
by the end of the film we learn that the
rooms were in fact designed by an
extremely powerful corporation we
discovered that the entire game is being
live-streamed to wealthy individuals who
have placed bets on who will survive and
who won't this holds extra weight when
we learn that the characters in the room
are actually all sold survivors
themselves zoe is the sole survivor of a
plane crash that killed her family which
is why the aeroplane appears on a coffee
mug in her room Amanda who is
ex-military survived an attack on a
convoy which caused her to have
third-degree burns which links into the
fire in the room designed for her Ben
was a drunk driver and the song that he
was listening to is branded on the key
for his room Jason was stranded at sea
and had to murder his friend in order to
fight hypothermia which involved taking
a red jacket from him to stay warm in
the freezing cold room we see another
character wear this jacket and it of
course has been placed there in
to trigger Jason it's also in this room
that Danny dies and we learned that he
was a survivor of carbon monoxide
poisoning hence the room that has this
aesthetic later in the movie
unfortunately Danny doesn't make it this
far and the rest of the survivors are
slowly killed off one by one until all
we are left with is Zoe Jason and Ben
Zoe splits up from the two and ends up
in a room that is being filled with
carbon monoxide which obviously links to
Danny Ben and Jason end up in a drug
infused room which causes them to
scramble for an antidote in which Ben
becomes the winner Ben then becomes
trapped in the final room and is
informed that no one actually survives
these rooms and that the entire run has
been solely for entertainment purposes
we learn that this is not the first time
that an experiment like this has been
done and there have been several escape
rooms in the past that have preceded
this one including ones involving people
from all walks of life
this one was deemed to be the most
interesting as mentioned earlier they
are all salt survivors but in the past
they've used athletes and just a general
range of the public just as things look
like they are over for Ben
Zoe returns it turns out that she
managed to find their gas masks in the
room ceiling similar to how they
descended on the airplane crash that she
survived Ben and Zoe managed to escape
the room and make it to a hospital where
they inform police however it's too late
and we discovered that all of the items
from the rooms have been completely
removed and whoever was behind this
entire thing has left no trace
we then flash forward a couple of months
to see that Ben and Zoe are now an item
similar to the survivors from saw Ben
has used the event to empower himself
and live a positive life whereas Zoe
wants revenge she has discovered that
the corporation behind the escape room
is called - and has located their
headquarters and wants to go and stop
them it seems like she's finally gonna
put an end to them but we in fact learn
that the corporation is aware of this
and has been planting seeds the entire
time to lead them to this conclusion we
watched the corporation preparing an
escape room for the - which shows that
they not only let Zoe find out their
location but they are once again turning
this into a big game it's a genius
closer for me and shows just how far
ahead the - Corporation are ahead of
them strategically hopefully we will see
this come to fruition in a sequel as I
can't wait to see what the corporation
have in store for the care of
des I loved this film and it kicks off
the year with a bang so what were your
thoughts on escape room did you enjoy it
and what do you hope to see in a sequel
if one ever gets made comment below and
let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of this week's other big
event black mirror Bandersnatch which
will be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are heavy into
horror so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
[Music]